bueno si la hora laguna y vengo a
hablado del futuro del ecofeminismo como
han comentado pero me gusta pensarlo
como el futuro de la sociedad global
mundial ahí es nada no para eso lo
primero que todo que contaros es el
contexto que es aquí donde viene el
bajón pero prometo ir remontando en la
charla vale el contexto es una crisis
multidimensional es decir una crisis
compuesta por varias crisis que se
suelen analizar por separado pero que se
entienden muchísimo mejor
si van juntas la primera es una crisis
climática desde el proceso de
industrialización que llevamos viviendo
las sociedades desde el siglo 18
nos hemos basado una premisa falsa la
premisa de que podemos crecer
ilimitadamente económicamente y un
consumo de materiales energía en un
planeta de recursos limitados es decir
estamos sobrepasando y en algunos casos
hemos sobrepasado ya los límites
biofísicos del planeta esto hace que
veamos una situación de emergencia
climática donde el problema más evidente
y más urgente también son la emisión de
gases de efecto invernadero
particularmente de dióxido de carbono
y yo no voy a pararme aquí en justificar
porque estamos en una situación de
emergencia porque uno creo que
deberíamos partir todas y todos de ese
marco dos hay consenso científico
internacional de sobra para no tener que
discutir esto esto excepto con un par de
trogloditas negacionistas pero en todos
deberíamos partir de aquí de hecho el
concepto de emergencia climática es
interesante porque en el último año lo
hemos escuchado mucho algunos países
incluido españa ha declarado la
emergencia climática
ahora toca actuar como si de verdad
estuviésemos en emergencia entonces si
esto va a ser papel mojado o un paquete
de medidas suerte valiente y eficiente
es algo que veremos e iremos valorando
estamos en una crisis ecológica y de
biodiversidad esto quiere decir que
estamos perdiendo muchísimas especies
nos encontramos en la sexta extinción
masiva de especies la primera por acción
antropogénica es decir por acción del
ser humano
un ejemplo que pongo siempre los
insectos a nadie le importan los
insectos nos molestan los insectos
estamos perdiendo una barbaridad de
insectos y la vida tal y como la
conocemos no se entiende ni se explica
ni se garantiza sin insectos
y es una crisis social y aquí hay una
paradoja bastante injusta que quiere
decir que las crisis anteriores que
hemos mencionado afectan desigualmente a
las personas de tal manera que las que
menos han contribuido a esta situación y
las que menos recursos tienen para
afrontarla son las que más sufren sus
consecuencias y esto se ve en los países
del norte global donde nos encontramos y
los países del sur global en el psuv
global se está viviendo ya perfectamente
lo que se denomina colapso se están
viviendo ya sequías migraciones ahí hay
una figura que es la del refugiado o
refugiada climática o climático esto es
algo que tenemos que tener en cuenta
otra parte del contexto que tenemos que
mencionar es sin duda el feminismo que
ha pasado con el feminismo pues que wii
que ha sufrido un gran auge los últimos
años e incluso hablamos de que nos
encontramos en la cuarta ola del
feminismo esto sería que viene marcada
por un rechazo a las violencias y
agresiones de carácter machista o por
razón de género y ahí vemos dos campañas
la del michu que ha sido súper famosa es
evita listo hace unos años pocos
y al lado tenemos esa performance que
ahora se está haciendo muy famosa y
también que él ha diseñado en el
colectivo las tesis un colectivo chileno
y es parte de un acto y la canción se
llama un violador en tu camino bueno
esto a día de hoy se ha visualizado y se
ha hecho mundial y ha contribuido a que
el discurso se hegemonice es decir poca
gente ya o eso quiero pensar yo duda de
la veracidad del feminismo si bien
también ha suscitado una respuesta
profundamente reaccionaria y eso también
tenemos que tenerlo en cuenta que el
auge del fascismo está aquí por el
feminismo sí pero por la crisis
ecológica también hay un concepto
interesante que se lee con fas cismo
una característica que a mí me encanta
del feminismo es que tiene capacidad de
dialogar con otros movimientos sociales
y con otras luchas tiene que trabajarla
pero está en ello y tiene un concepto
muy interesante la intersección alidad
nos dice que hay distintos ejes de
opresión distintos ejes de
vulnerabilidad el sexo puede ser uno la
identidad de género la nacionalidad el
estatus social la clase la diversidad
funcional
hay muchos ejes de tal manera que no no
vimos el mujer que ser mujer y negra que
ser mujer negra y lesbiana que ser mujer
negra y lesbiana y que te falten las dos
piernas todo esto suma para que seas una
persona más o menos vulnerable
y aquí viene el tercer pilar del
contexto que ellos quería comentar que
es el papel de la juventud la juventud
está renovado su papel como agente de
cambio como sujeto político y lo hemos
visto sobre todo en el último año donde
movimientos como haydée esfuerzo lucha
que es un movimiento ecologista y joven
se ha hecho mundialmente conocido está
en más de 185 países y tiene un lema muy
interesante que dice sin planeta no hay
futuro y esto viene muy a colación de la
charla de hoy nada a ninguno de los
futuros que estamos pintando imaginando
o soñando son posibles si el planeta no
se mantiene que aún así esto es falso
porque el planeta pervivirá pero si
nosotras y si nosotros y de hecho el año
2019 se puede considerar año de las
movilizaciones por el clima en general
pero también las estudiantiles y
juveniles porque la juventud ha sido muy
protagonista en todo esto que tiene de
interesante la juventud que por un lado
tiene muy asumido el discurso feminista
y es bastante consciente mucho más que
las generaciones predecesoras en general
tiene muy asumido el discurso feminista
y también es muy consciente de las
desigualdades sociales y al mismo tiempo
sufre mucho más las cosas
de la crisis climática son las que más
la van a sufrir el futuro es bastante
incierto todo va a cambiar por eso la
juventud ahora se está levantando con un
mensaje común que es no tenemos futuro
es un poco desalentador lo sé ya yo creo
que vamos a ir terminando el momento
bajón
poco a poco y aquí es donde ellos quiero
hablar del ecofeminismo porque claro una
juventud concienciada y en riesgo es la
puerta de entrada para el ecofeminismo
que es una teoría muy diversa hay varios
sector feminista yo vengo hablar del
ecofeminismo crítico de la ilustrada que
es el que defiendo pero existen muchos y
todos son interesantes y todos aportan
podemos definirlo de muchas maneras al
fin y al cabo el ecofeminismo analista
muchas facetas de la vida pero de manera
sencilla es el punto de encuentro de
feminismo y ecologismo y diréis y esto
qué significa bueno es que podemos ver
puntos de encuentro muy claros a lo
largo de la charla iremos viendo quizá
algunos pero yo os voy a poner un
ejemplo hay muchas mujeres o personas en
general que se consideran feministas
pero no ecologistas y entonces yo yo soy
feminista pero no ecologista me enfundó
mi camiseta
y eslogan feminista no todo el mundo
debería ser feminista
y resulta que esa camiseta está cosida
bangladesh por mujeres y niñas en
situación de semiesclavitud y que además
de nuestra textil es de las más
contaminantes en el mundo y además
sabemos que las mujeres sobre todo las
del sur global están sufriendo las
consecuencias de la crisis climática
hombre pues muy feminista no soy porque
si no me preocupo por la totalidad de
las mujeres entonces no es no tengo una
sonoridad perdón una sonoridad
internacional que sería un concepto muy
interesante que deberíamos buscar
también poder ser ecologista y que me
dio igual el feminismo y luchar por la
naturaleza pero perpetuar las dinámicas
de poder y de opresión sobre las mujeres
y esto se ve en los colectivos
ecologistas sobre todo los que tienen
uno
perdón por suerte los colectivos jóvenes
tienen mucho más asumido todo esto es lo
garantizo
hay dos autoras ayb en su libro el de
alicia puleo que se llama clave con
feministas para rebeldes que aman a la
tierra ya los animales que analizan muy
bien todo esto y los invito muchísimo a
que lo escuchéis porque una charla tan
breve no da para explicar el
ecofeminismo pero dice todos los
sistemas de dominación están vinculados
a nivel conceptual a través de una
lógica como la lógica de la dominación
esto explica que los hombres dominan a
las mujeres los seres humanos a los
animales no humanos que la ciencia de
algún modo domina la naturaleza y el
resto de opresiones si conseguimos
entender las violencias sistemáticas de
manera conjunta también somos capaces de
combatirla de manera conjunta
probablemente de manera más eficaz eso
es lo que nos propone el ecofeminismo
en dos conceptos muy interesantes del
ecofeminismo por un lado la
interdependencia que tenemos que
asumirlos ya para transformar la
sociedad la interdependencia significa
que todas la todos los seres humanos
somos dependientes los unos de los otros
vivimos en la fantasía de que somos
independientes individuales porque el
dinero lo compra todo pero es mentira y
en algunos momentos de la vida se nota
más que en otros evidentemente la
infancia requerimos más cuidados en la
vejez requerimos más cuidados en
situación de enfermedad requerimos más
cuidados y sobre quién recaen esos
cuidados mayoritariamente sobre las
mujeres invisibiliza de manera
visibilizada sin remuneración con
condiciones precarias
y también cuando estamos en situación de
exclusión social ojo ahí también nos
necesitamos unas a otras la
codependencia por su parte sería este
concepto que nos dice que los seres
humanos estamos insertos en la
naturaleza somos parte de ella y somos
animales aunque se nos haya olvidado y
todo lo que vestimos todo lo que comemos
todo lo que hacemos depende de la
naturaleza con lo cual la
interdependencia es el concepto que me
trae el feminismo y la epo dependencia
es el concepto que me trae el ecologismo
aquí ya quizá podamos empezar a ver qué
puntos de unión tienen pero claro yo mi
tema de estudios la salud con lo cual os
la voy a colar con la salud y es que
resulta ahí tienen su libro de
carnavales que os recomiendo
profundamente ya sonando que no lo va a
catalana ya ha estudiado mucho todo esto
y ella dice en general en las sociedades
occidentales como la nuestra estamos en
contacto con unas 80.000 sustancias
químicas de las cuales entre 4.000 y
8.000 están bajo sospecha de toxicidad
hay poco estudiado al respecto de hecho
se está viendo una proliferación grande
de enfermedades que se vinculan con todo
esto pero está por estudiar
claro no todas las personas están
igualmente en contacto con estas
sustancias químicas y tóxicas y no todas
las personas sufren las consecuencias
por igual esto va a depender de factores
biológicos pero también de factores
sociales biológicos la edad por ejemplo
influye porque el sistema nervioso en
etapas en la infancia por ejemplo en la
vejez es mucho más vulnerable el sexo y
aquí perdonadme hablo de mujeres y no de
mujeres trans porque la ciencia tiene
los mismos sesgos que tenemos en la
sociedad y si la sociedad entendemos los
humanos en dos categorías varones y
mujeres categorías estancas pues la
ciencia por desgracia también lo estuve
así pero ya sabemos que esto a veces no
es suficiente para explicar la gran
diversidad que hay hoy en día
el sexo también es un factor de riesgo
ante las sustancias químicas porque el
cuerpo de las mujeres tiene mucho más
porcentaje de tejido adiposo esto nos
convierte en bio acumuladoras porque
muchas de las sustancias tóxicas y
químicas se acumulan en la grasa sólidos
solubles entonces acumulamos muchas más
sustancias tóxicas y además nuestro
sistema endocrino es una puerta de
entrada os invito de verdad que
profundice jce porque es súper
interesante también de factores sociales
claro podemos hablar de las condiciones
laborales que en general los comedores
en las mujeres podemos hablar de
precariedad la pobreza es mucho mayor en
mujeres y sigue aumentando y además en
situación de crisis las desigualdades
sociales aumentan con lo cual la brecha
de género aumentará la brecha de clase
aumentará los ricos serán más ricos los
pobres serán más actores ya está pasando
y todo esto combina con otros ejes la
racialización por ejemplo el ser una
persona racializada el pertenecer a un
colectivo lgtb y todo esto puede hacer
que tengamos un desigual acceso a los
recursos sanitarios o por ejemplo que
las personas trans estén mucho menos
estudiadas que las personas que están
invisibilizadas igual que también hemos
estado durante mucho tiempo las mujeres
y aún seguimos estando lo por tanto las
mujeres tenemos un doble para un doble
papel frente a esta crisis de la que yo
os hablo por un lado somos las
principales víctimas y es que os pongo
un ejemplo las sufragistas fueron las
primeras anti vivisección istas esto
quiere decir que fueron de las primeras
animalistas defensoras de los animales y
ahí aquí tenéis en la foto esa berta
cáceres que es una lideresa lenta una
activista hondureña que defendía a las
mujeres ya su territorio como muchas
otras y que fue asesinada precisamente
por este motivo yo siempre quiero
mencionar esto porque considero que ser
decir que soy feminista o ecologista en
esta sociedad bueno se pueden reír de mí
se pueden meter conmigo y las cenas de
navidad son muy duras solo garantizo
pero al margen de eso mi integridad
física en principio y de momento no
corre ningún riesgo ahora bien no es tan
fácil decir esto mismo en otros países y
esto quiero traerlo aquí quiero tenerlo
en cuenta no me olvido de que soy blanca
y privilegiada y esto es importante para
que sepamos de dónde hablamos por tanto
doble papel de las mujeres por eso es
otro punto de encuentro entre ecologismo
y ecologismo
ante toda esta situación con la siesta y
deprimente que os he planteado qué
propuestas trae el ecofeminismo pues
muchísimas porque el ecofeminismo
analiza la economía las relaciones
interpersonales los cuidados los
autocuidados la política la salud la
ciencia
los procesos de producción los hábitos
de consumo la alimentación todo lo que
queráis lo analiza el ecofeminismo he
elegido unas pocas que me parecían un
poco didácticas y que pienso que nos
pueden servir porque al final para que
os estoy contando esto pues con la idea
quizá utópica de transformar la sociedad
y de transformarla en una dirección
hacia la dirección de que sea más justa
en todos los sentidos y que sea más
sostenible en primer lugar tenemos que
reconocer los distintos sistemas de
opresión los mencionada antes hablamos
de patriarcado el capitalismo del
colonialismo del antropocentrismo porque
como decíamos si los si tenemos visión
del conjunto podemos establecer
sinergias entre ellos o lo que es lo
mismo establecer pactos de ayuda mutua
aprender de otros movimientos ayudarnos
en la medida de lo posible y también
otras personas
hay que recuperar las relaciones
comunitarias reinventar lo colectivo el
capitalismo nos quiere individuales y
nos ha vendido la idea de que somos
independientes pero es mentira y de
hecho en otras sociedades quizá más
cerca de pueblos originarios o tribus
indígenas los haberes comunitarios son
importantísimos aquí los estamos
perdiendo los normal vivimos en ciudades
y vivimos prácticamente en colmenas pero
hay que recuperar y hay que renunciar a
la idea de crecimiento ilimitado por lo
que contábamos porque no podemos crecer
ilimitadamente en un planeta de recursos
limitados que además están cerca de
agotarse
una redistribución de la riqueza no es
ningún secreto que los mal denominados
recursos y digo mal denominados porque
no me gusta esta palabra parece que
alguien ha puesto ahí la naturaleza para
que nosotras y nosotros hagamos uso de
ella y eso es irreal estos recursos la
inmensa mayoría recaen en manos de muy
pocos y cada vez de menos estoy que
redistribuirlo es de todas es de todos
hay que valorar y cuidar la diversidad
en lugar de excluir la en lugar de
invisibilizar la en lugar de aplastarla
tenemos que aprender porque somos una
sociedad diversa y cada vez más y
siempre siempre siempre con un horizonte
común de justicia social y justicia
climática no existe lo uno sin lo otro y
necesitamos ambas terminó con las
palabras
de berta cáceres la activista de la que
os hablaba antes que dice construyamos
sociedades capaces de existir de manera
justa digna y por la vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]